Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 4th,
2012 2012 how are you?
How's it going? I know, I know. It's
a little late. It's a little late,
but you know,
can't you just go twiddle your thumbs
and do something else for a minute?
You know, set a going on my Twitter
and breaking my balls. I know what,
just take a pill. You don't really
don't have a fucking day job.
So there's really no excuse for
you having this podcast late.
Once again.
Well listen,
if you notice like axl rose,
I am also a balding
redheaded performer and
yeah,
now we're notorious for starting shows
late for sitting in our trailers,
you know, making sure our
kilts fit correctly. Um,
that's when you knew that band was just
fucking really was just going over the
top and there was nobody saying no in
their camp when he came out. You know,
when the war, the kilt is, it's
what woody you doing. All right.
You're not Scottish. I'm sure you have
some sort of Scottish heritage, you,
ginger bested in your blood.
But you know,
you from fucking Rhode Island
or where they like Indianapolis.
Well that was he from Illinois.
What? You're in America,
it's not a kilt. Let's it's Saint
Patrick's Day, Saint Patrick's Day.
I'll look the other way. Other than
that, you were at a fucking dress.
You know who stole it?
Years later,
Kurt Cobain came out wearing a summer
dress cause he was sad and he thought
maybe if he felt a little
pretty that you know, uh,
Jesus fill you really going to say,
well fuck it.
I'll say maybe he wouldn't stick a
fucking gun in his mouth. You know,
when the fuck do you get off
making fun of the, Oh fuck you. Um,
believe it or not, I'm
actually in a great mood. Um,
the rest of the reason why I was late
today, this is my ex, this is my,
the dog ate my homework. Excuse
was a, I finally went out, uh,
riding a motorcycle today. That's
what I did. I had a manly morning.
What did you do? Huh? You sit down
and eat some fucking lucky charms. Hi,
you pansy. You sit in there smelling
like gas. I don't think you are,
is there any worse than when somebody
just picks up a new hobby and then they go
out and they just buy all the gear and
then they start walking around like the
fucking Clint Eastwood?
Well, lucky for you guys.
I'm not one of those guys.
And the only reason why I'm not
is because I'm an old bastard now.
And one of the great things about being
in an old bastard about being an old
bastard,
one of the great things aside from
having an enlarged prostate is,
is you know your limits.
You've gotten fucked up.
Somebody kicked you in the head by now.
You fell down a flight of stairs.
You fucked up some relationships.
You know people you know have
gotten fucked to you. You realize,
you realize there's not some dude in
the air that gives a shit about you.
You know that you have some sort of
guardian angel just looking out for you.
Now, if you're a fucking idiot,
eventually you're gonna get fucked up.
Why is that true though? There's a
couple of golden childs out there. No,
it doesn't. Everybody just know that
guy that you've just been predicting.
You know, a guy's going to
get his fucking ass kicked.
I'm telling it's going to
happen. Remember, remember,
remember this conversation?
Remember I said it? Okay, well fucking
guy, he doesn't show any respect.
He's always running his fucking Yap.
I tell you,
I would've done it if I didn't
have so much to loose, you know,
I would have kicked his fucking ass
if a x, Y and Z in this scenario.
My wife wasn't yelling at me,
you know,
and he just keep predicting that this
guy is going to get his ass kicked.
And you know, there's always that guy
where it just never happens. And uh,
once they hit 40 and if you've met,
he never got your ass kicked by 40.
I,
it's pretty much not going to happen
unless there's some sort of home invasion,
you know,
I would think,
or unless for some reason you'd
take up drugs late in your life,
right? You end up eating
somebody who's fucking face
and growing at the cops.
It's just, you know,
isn't it unbelievable that I refuse
to watch that video? And if you, I,
if you watched that video like before,
if you haven't watched it yet, you know,
just
those videos,
that's like getting just deliberately
putting a virus on your computer.
You don't want that shit in your own
personal hard drive. You don't want that.
You don't want that roll around in your
head. You don't want to see that shit.
You have a fucking meat.
Like you know,
veterans who've really seen some shit
be it military or cops or whatever,
prison guards,
they got that look on their face.
They just seen too much shit.
Christmas music starts fading
away in the background.
He just see why would you deliberately
do that to yourself? All right,
it already sounded horrific enough.
It's already making my stomach
turn. I mean, that's just
what kind of world we live in.
Whether could something like that app,
that's the new drug. I mean,
on one hand you got to hang it,
hand it to the youngsters,
you know, every time you know,
you think your generation
has taken it to the limit,
the next generation somehow
figures out a way to top you.
It's one of the great
things about human beings.
That's why cars keep getting better,
right?
People figure out how to make a sandwich
a little more tasty, or it just,
you just keep improving. And uh,
but that also goes with evil shit.
And I always thought,
you know,
the crack eighties when I saw crack
babies, I was like, that's it.
I don't know how you top that.
You know,
some little shiver and fucking Guinea pig
of a kid. Never had a god damn chance.
Comes out addicted to crack.
How do you beat that? You know?
And then along came meth heads,
right?
That's always the beginning
of some spinoff Sitcom, right?
Like meth heads was the flow
from Alice to crack babies.
If you were making a sitcom about drug
use, you know, male kiss my grits.
That was fucking methods. Just
go with me on this. There'll be,
what else are you going to do?
He go to work.
Sit in your cubicle and
actually get something done
and aren't a fucking living.
That's right. Wrinkly. Your fucking knows
it. Me and my podcast. What are you doing?
Huh?
Eating those yellow Oreo cookies you got
down from the vending machine at those
tasty. They are, aren't they? Now
your blood sugar's starting to crash.
Look at you.
Big stupid head on your head and acting
like you're trying to figure something
out on your computer.
You're not, you know,
maybe you're in an airport and you just
finished off some fucking horrible food
right now you're going to go waddle
your ass onto a God damn airplane. Um,
that was, it has to do with anything from
oil. So anyways, then you had meth heads
who I thought were basically
real life zombies as far as,
as far as you could take it. And then
along comes this guy along came Polly,
right?
Just like the movie,
except Phillip Seymour Hoffman
is eaten somebodies face.
How great is that fucking
basketball scene by the way?
Ray Dad's old,
old schools the best.
Um,
eating somebody God damn face.
I refuse to believe that that's
the drug's fault. I think you, you,
you gotta be like already a maniac
and then you do some new psycho drug.
But who knows? Maybe that's the new thing.
Maybe that's what the kids are doing.
Ugh.
And then the guy fucking survives and
now you're in the hospital. I mean,
I would just be like,
dude,
kill me if I was laying in a hospital
bed and then they're acting like they're
going to somehow a fucking do a face
transplant on me. Like from what
bill? I think you Harrison there. Listen,
we have your stabilized,
we've got new.
I would immediately just,
I would be just start feeling around
my hospital table for a pen and I would
just be like, shoot me. Actually,
you know what? I wouldn't,
I wouldn't because then
they would be like, well,
we have to prevent him from doing what
he wants to do to himself right now.
And uh, so I actually, I wouldn't
say that I would just write oh great.
On a post it and then stick
it to my nonexistent forehead
and I just keep pointing to it every time
they talked to me. And then the second,
yeah, I felt like I was
alone. I would, I do it.
Oh,
that'd be great.
Just rule right out the fucking hospital
window with your ass hanging out of the
bag of that robe. I'm sorry. I feel
bad for that guy and everything. I'm,
I'm not fun of that guy.
But
like I don't have the internal strength
like you ever see that shit like when uh,
like Christopher Reeve
gets thrown off a horse,
hits the ground like a fucking lawn,
darts snaps his neck and then the next
Oscar she's willing himself out with is
like tongue smiling at the crowd.
Like I feel fortunate to be alive.
I feel lucky. There's no fucking way. If
I'm ever presented with that challenge,
we're going to handle that even remotely,
dignified way. There's no
fucking way I'm Gunna, I,
I'm not as strong as those people.
I'll just be, I will just be, you know,
like I said,
sounds great.
Was going to be right on my fucking
forehead and I'm going to steer my chair
right down a flight of stairs
and that's it. It's over.
I'm willing to roll with it.
Dice,
you know about what happens
after you after here personally,
you know,
he's fucking people who,
who go through shit like that and then
are able to continue on with their lives
and they give you see these fucking
people, they're like, you know,
writing a fucking novel with
their left foot. You know,
I'm sitting, I've girls like take out
the recycling. I'm like, AH, fuck.
I mean I just, you know,
if there is a higher power,
I think he knows who to fucking challenge.
He's taking a look at me again.
Oh Geez, you should, we'll let
that one go. It's fucking asshole.
Can't even make the goddamn bed.
I'm going to send him flying off a
fucking horse. He gets serious. Um,
so anyways, let's get on with my
day here. I had a phenomenal day.
I went a dirt bike riding this
morning for the first time ever.
Never rode a motorcycle.
Um, and I got a minute.
I did all right for now.
I was driving around for like an
hour and then next thing you know,
they talked me into going out on the track
where they had jumps and shit. And, uh,
but it wasn't like, you know,
they were fucking steep for me,
but they had like the plateaus he could
ride ride over on like a little bitch,
which,
uh,
is exactly what I did and it's why I
didn't get hurt a couple times. So,
you know, I got into like second
gear and I kind of was like, whoa.
When there was like a fucking fence with
a telephone pole and I was like, yeah,
you know what?
I don't want to be doing that.
I don't want to be fucking laying there,
you know,
with my rib cage slammed
into all my vitals. I don't
feel like doing that. So I,
you know, I kept it slow. Then
I got on the track and uh,
it was hilarious. I thought it was
flying when I was on the track,
but someone was taking video of it,
which I will give you. I will, uh,
put up on the podcast
page hopefully if, if, uh,
it's sent to me by the time I post this,
I'll definitely at least have some photos,
but I thought I was flying right. Like,
Hey Dad,
dad that was flying.
I watched the video, it
looked like may, may,
maybe it looked like I was riding like
a fucking moped, but, um, anyways,
I drove around for like two hours,
got it down pretty God damn good.
And I only ate shit once I was on
the track and every, I don't know,
even know what happened. I was
like, I was off and then I wasn't,
it was like a goddess.
It's going good man. I'm
going to kick up some dirt and that
was, it. Landed on my shoulder,
jacked up my thumb a little bit. And you
know what I did? The old man in me said,
you know what bill? You know what I
think, I think that's good for a day.
I think that's good. I rode right off the
track. I went around at one more time,
you know, just so I'm not like
afraid of it. And then I, uh,
I just went over and I pulled up to
the truck and I got some water that an
instructor dude came up day, you want to
ride around? And again, I was like, Nah,
you know what I think of
good one face plant is good.
I've got a podcast I have to do.
I got the gist of this shit.
I'll definitely be coming back. It's a
great time, man. It was such a good time.
I uh, took my truck out there
and met the, a buddy of mine,
he had the body who was getting a
couple of bikes just uh, just a,
an adventure today, you
know, we got off at the exit,
there was these two
dogs that look healthy.
They just running down the
fucking highway, tongues
hanging out like, you know,
big spoon tongs. And we were
uh, pulled over, picked him up,
gave him some water, uh, parked in
the shade, let them hang out there.
Fucking awesome dogs.
They were filthy,
but they were well fed
and they had collars.
So we, um, it was hilarious. Like
right next to the track was this guy,
he had like a fucking,
uh,
just was living in like a double wide,
like motorcross she there for two
seconds and you just feel it. It is,
it is a white trash sport.
That's why I loved it. You know,
my fucking inner redneck, you know, I
mean you could just feel it, you know,
gas gears, meth, the whole fucking
thing was right there, you know,
mullets
you know,
everybody this sucked at math,
but they can convert a lawnmower into
like a fucking Ferrari if they had to,
you know, or at least a
Mustang, a that whole vibe.
So right next to the track was,
um,
this guy had like a double wide,
he had like fucking 20 dogs.
So the dude who picked up the dogs,
it's going,
let's just drop them cause we yelling
in, the guy didn't come. I'm like,
let's just drop him over
the fence. And I, you know,
I watched that dog whisperers shit.
And I see like when a dog comes up to the
pack and everybody starts freaking out
and I'm like, I dunno
about this guys. I Dunno.
So we lift the dogs up and
the pack media says like,
Oh fuck is, look, I not a
good idea that it got it.
We're almost through
these dogs to their death.
So we ended up putting
them back in the truck.
I know there's a couple of people who
know a lot of stuff about dogs right now.
Don't worry. It has a happy ending.
Okay? So you can relax. All right.
Get off the edge of your staples seat.
Uh,
your Ikea Chair. Um, this has a good
ending. So we ended up going to the track.
We parked in the shade and the
dog's immediately just, you know,
passed out there was so exhausted,
pour things and um,
they were friendly as hell.
So when we were done,
we ended up just looking up,
uh,
the humane society and they had a drop
off and we went over there and we came
walking in with them, didn't have leashes
where like carrying him in and shit.
And, uh, we come walking in like, hey, how
you doin? My whole head is like, please,
you're not going to kill these
dogs in like 20 minutes. Right?
So we brought him in a second.
We came walking in and they were like,
Jesus Christ, those dogs it back again.
Uh, we know those dogs and you know,
they had, they were microchipped
scanned them and shit and uh,
which was unsettling because one
of my buddies is going like, oh,
these things are micro
checked, chipped, you know.
Then the conspiracy theorist in
me is just like, yeah, we're next.
It's what they're going to do.
A,
they bring us into after we escape a
FEMA camp on your papers for the ease and
they get a fucking Tapley you scan you
and send you right back to your camp and
Fresno. Um, but let's get back to the
happy ending. So they knew the dogs,
they scanned them,
they called the owner and then the,
they ended up coming down and get the
dog. So we did a good day. All right.
That's why the podcast is late because
I was acting like a fucking eight year
old,
but we rescued dogs along the way.
Isn't that a nice story?
I got to tell you something.
If you've never gone dirt bike
ride and you've got to do it.
And I can't imagine when I saw some of
the kids down there getting a ride those
bikes,
like how fucking incredible that must be.
You know,
cause I remember you were a kid,
you just sit in there
and riding in the back,
you're always the passenger and then
all of a sudden one day you turned 15,
15 and a half, he gets your permit next.
Neil, you're driving down the street.
It's the greatest fucking feeling
ever to feel that at eight to go from
literally like
to like fucking a half hour later.
But
flying around the track,
it's just incredible to me. Um, but
anyways, it was an awesome time.
And uh,
I dunno,
but I don't know if I have time for
another hobby and I got to tell you like,
um, you know, it was fun
but it's fucking scary.
I didn't know I was doing at one point,
like I let out the clutch and I just
started flying them in the parking lot.
It's all dirt and I'm heading
towards these trees and these cars.
And fortunately I remain
calm and I had to, like,
I had to like think, what do you do? A
push in the clutch and here's the break.
Okay. And it's the exact opposite where,
you know, I'm used to driving my truck,
I push in the clutch with my foot breaks,
obviously what the foot,
and now it's the opposite
unless she used the back brake,
which is on the right side
of the whole fucking thing.
But I was able to remain calm
and it was hilarious.
I stopped and when I turned around,
I saw everybody in the parking lot was
laughing and I was just sitting there
like, dude, I am just a fucking
youtube video waiting to Ha I this,
I should have had epic fail,
uh,
written across my shoulders.
It was,
it was a little sketchy in the beginning,
but I just kept, you know, you know,
I watched a couple of youtube videos on
how to ride a motorcycle and they were
just like, look, just keep, you know,
he'd in first gear, let out the clutch,
get going a little bit and
then learn how to stop.
And they just keep doing
that over and over again.
So I just kept doing
So once you can slow the
fucker down your right and uh,
I would say I got it into second gear
a couple of times, but like I said,
I wasn't, uh, you know,
I wasn't trying to break my collarbone
or even worse fucking via lawn dart right
into the, I'm just not,
I'm not, I'm too old.
I can't make a comeback from that shit,
you know, you know, kids are all positive.
They like fall out of a skyscraper
and like, yeah, I'm good. You know,
put on some cartoons and they're like
up and walking in like a week like that,
that would have broke me as a human being.
I'm not, I'm just a shit talk and asshole.
But when it comes to stuff like that,
like I'm not a, I know my
limits, I fucking know him.
There's a couple of times I got it up in
second gear and that fucking voice that
you ignore when you're a youngster,
that voice that's going, dude,
what the fuck are you doing?
And just plays out the scenario,
you know,
of laying in the back of the ambulance
and that guy flashing the pen light in
your eyes.
Just playing out that scenario and all
the canceled gigs I would have and a in
every time, you know, and fucking
it's below 30 degrees out.
My fucking liver hurts.
Like I just played all of that.
Every time I thought of that, I
just kept slowing down. So, but uh,
it was fucking awesome man.
And uh, and that's it. They go,
there's my dirt bike story. That's
why I'm late. All right. Um,
okay, so this is the Monday morning
podcast. Everybody did you got you.
Did you watch some fucking sports
about them South Dick's to fucking say
I fucking said it.
Oh yeah.
Fuck you set your fucking cunt dude,
I'm the fucking Celtics tied it up.
Holy Shit. Amazing. I gotta
tell you something right now.
I have the utmost respect
for fans of the NBA.
It is the most fucked
up nerve wracking game.
It's, it's, I can't even explain it.
No team can go up by 20 points
and fucking hold the lead.
They just can't do it by 24.
And then all of a sudden stern calls the
refs to fuck you guys doing the rule is
15 points, 15 or more. And then they
just start Twitter eight to tweet,
tweet, tweet, fall away
from the ball. And you know,
I've never watched this sport where you
hear the announcers review a call like
six times a gave. They go, I dunno what
he was looking at there. Then he lays,
Rondo,
pushes the ball up court.
You know how many fucking times?
It's the most frustrating
sport I've ever in my life.
When the Celtics were up by,
uh,
we got like 15 or whatever scored 61 of
the first half and then all of sudden
you've got 28 in the second half.
It's like, what is going on with that?
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Like when a pitcher comes out and
he's on and he's got his stuff,
he has his stuff,
he doesn't like pitch pitch lights out
for four ratings and then like let up
like 19 fucking home runs
doesn't happen.
Fucking NBA.
They said they were up by 24 points
and then all of a sudden did you,
they can't get a call,
they can't get a bucket and all of a
sudden it said it's up fucking four point
nail biter.
We were up by 24 points after three
quarters game 3:24 PM if you scored 24
points,
that's a solid quarter with the fucking
points and somehow it went down to being
like an eight point game and I was just
losing my shit and the Moros watching it.
I was just convinced that
it's manipulated by the refs.
I don't give a fuck what you say.
There's no other official that has
more power than an NBA referee.
They can kick people out
of the fucking game. Okay.
You can call attentional grounding on
Peyton manning. You can call a, you know,
some bullshit forward
lateral or some crap,
but you can't kick Tom Brady out of the
Goddamn game unless he throws a punch.
You know what I mean?
I guess she can,
as he verbally abuse you or touched
the ribbon, he asked to do something,
but in basketball you can just
call phantom fouls. Like if, I bet,
if I bet the game, this is all you got to
do. Who's the best player on their team?
This is what you do right out of the gate.
You give him two quick fouls.
Now he's on the fucking bench probably
for the rest of the first quarter.
He comes out in the second quarter.
Now you got to give him his third,
but you know, you got to
wait a few minutes, you know,
however the game's going.
You wait a few minutes. Then he
gave him his third. All right,
so and so's in foul trouble.
Third quarter starts,
he's on the fucking bench and now you
want the other team to make a run.
The Fuck Oh comes off the bench.
You give him his fourth tee them up.
Maybe a couple of technicals there.
I think I watched that game yesterday.
It goes into overtime.
It's a playoff game.
Paul Pierce files out
Lebron James Fouls out
two fucking best guys out there arguably,
you know, and it's sitting on the bench.
You don't watch hockey and
all of a sudden fucking,
you know whoever you want to call the Fox,
even in the finals now
[inaudible] you know Zach Parisi,
however the fuck you say their names,
they hate the doubles. I never watch him,
you know?
Oh that's his third fucking cross check
that said he's out of the game and like
the like Gretzky and Lemieux are
just sitting there on the bench,
fouled out and then like the scrubs
come in and they can't hit fucking free
throws. I, I just, it's
unbelievably frustrating,
frustrating fucking game to watch.
But we're tied up with tied up.
So did that make any god damn sense
if you guys ever watched those
youtube videos when you see a,
okay,
what, when you see what's his face when
you see that whole Sacramento Series,
Sacramento Kings,
but was it against the El La Lakers in
2002 a series that was allegedly fixed?
Um,
you saw right there I to fix a game.
They just filed out both their centers
on bullshit fucking calls and a then it
is let's shack run wild and
they still almost lost the game.
I don't know man.
You know what it is.
I'm so sick of people like being a hockey
fan unless you run into another hockey
fan.
It's the weirdest sport to be a fan of.
Cause people just shit all at
well why did they let them fight?
I can't see the puck. And after watching
the NBA for like the last three weeks,
it's like why don't you worry about the
mobbed up refs in your league? You know,
I think the NBA is, is basically, it's
a pure game. It's a beautiful gay,
but it's basically a traveling
gambling ring as far as I can tell.
The players gamble with each other.
They get into fistfights on planes,
they bring guns to the fucking arena.
You had a mobbed up ref, you know,
and then they pulled the Lee Harvey
Oswald, he acted alone. Horse Shit. Right?
You have the biggest star of the game.
It has to mysteriously just
retired for a year and a half.
And then one of his loved ones essentially
is murdered like execution style.
Like there's a lot of shit.
There's a lot of shit going on.
So why don't you go fuck yourselves
with your criticisms of hockey? Okay.
I can recognize NBA is a great
game. But uh, your, your league,
it's a little fucked up. And as far
as you guys who can't see the Puck,
why don't you start by looking at the guy
that everybody seems to be focused on.
All right.
That's usually the guy with the puck,
the black object against the white surface
that you, for some reason kids see,
um, speaking of which I'm trying
to go to game for the La Kings
in, what's the best thing about, uh,
about the La Kings making the playoffs
is listening to the local spa sports
radio shows like half to talk hockey.
Dude,
they are fucking flailing out
here and this or that, that,
that Max and Marcellus show.
That's the show I always listened
to and they're great and everything,
but when it comes to hockey,
they don't know a fucking thing.
Max is just hitting you with basic fell.
They got there quicker than
any other team. A big team.
They're playing together. He's nothing.
The guy's got nothing. This is funny.
Like two weeks early,
I was listening to his show and some
jackass called him was go, yeah,
I'm a casual fan of hockey. I go to
a couple of games a year, you know,
if they just would tell you what a
cross check is, it's like right there.
It's like, dude, you're not a casual
fucking fant. That'd be like me saying,
I'm a casual fan of the NBA.
I go to a couple games a year.
If they just tell me what traveling is,
it's like,
how do you not pick that up within
the first fucking period and a half?
All the criticism, criticism will gets
hockey silver. I love when they go,
why do they have two half times it's like,
dude,
why don't you go back to basic math and
realize that it's mathematically you
can't have two half,
right?
They have a third time
and a two thirds time.
We want to get tech technical.
Correct. All right. Anyways,
this is the podcast. Hey,
you know what time it is?
It's time for some fucking advertising.
What are you safe days
coming up every body?
If it wasn't for your dad looking
at your mom wanting to get down,
you wouldn't be here, right? This
is the thing about mother's Day.
You go all out on mother's Day. Everybody
does, right? You just go all out.
She your mom, she's a saint, right?
You go all out and what happens?
Father's Day.
Your father is basically Walter Payton
and Superbowl 20 remember they let the
fridge, the fridge is your mom, right?
The fucking popular one handed off to her
and sweetness doesn't get a touchdown.
All right, well I think it's high time.
You let your dad fucking run one in.
All right, and you can do
it with the man. Great.
What is the man great you you ask?
Well,
when you go out and you
look at your father's grill,
he's going to have one of those grills
where they have those little skinny
little grills. You know what I
mean? That you couldn't even,
you couldn't even put like a,
a cheese it on without it falling through.
You know, this is what
the man great is. It's a,
basically it's a grill enhancement system,
which means you don't have to go buy a
new grill. This is going to enhance it.
You ever go into those awesome
steakhouses and you look at this,
this psycho Musky grill that they have
and those really thick a grates that they
have and the little,
the little moat thing to catch the grease.
So there's no grease fires. They
basically, they finally made one,
I don't know why it took so
long for someone to do this,
but they finally made one
for your grill at home,
which basically now you're
going to get the, the, the, the,
the look and the flavor of a
real steak house. All right,
Bay and this is the best part is 100% made
in America. Cast iron, grilling greats.
What do we make in
America? We'd, and this,
I think that's all we have left.
All right.
This is actually legal in all 50 states.
All right?
100% a made in America cast iron,
iron grilling grades,
they're heavy duty grilling grades deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
steakhouse flavor that
you've been looking for.
A man grades got the patent and
design is great for chicken, steak,
veggies and all that stuff was
never going to taste so good.
You don't have any more flip
flare ups or dry meat guaranteed.
Take advantage of the $20 Monday morning
podcast special today by clicking on
May on the man great banner@billboard.com.
Just go on the podcast page. Um,
as a bonus, every bill bird.com order
comes with a heavy duty man. Great Bro.
Grilling brush. Come on man. That's
what you buy your dad right there. Okay.
That's one.
Buying your dad a man great
for father's is one rung below.
Just buying them like an old pistol.
It's just a manly thing to
get them 100% made in America.
100% cast darn steak house quality.
$20 off and you get your little,
your little wire brush there.
Huh? Who's hooking you up?
Who's hooking you up? Well,
how could you do better?
How could you do better?
You know,
get them a hookah
dad, you've been faithful all these years.
Oh wait, here's a, here's a, a is a,
an email from somebody talking about
NBA reps because that was like convinced
that the NBA is fixed or at the
very least manipulated, you know?
Oh my God, the lottery. Are you serious?
Okay.
The lottery.
The Knicks when the first one ever,
because you want Patrick Ewing to go
to New York City course. Absolutely.
Um, the fall away from the ball. I
don't know why he was looking at their,
um,
be rest.
Bill saw your tweet about NBA reps and
how they are in it for the money. Well,
it's the truth. Uh, this guy's
claiming that this is the truth.
This is all alleged before I get sued
by a conglomerate of those footlocker
jackasses.
I'm friends with the daughter of one of,
one of the top paid reps in the league.
I just went to a wedding on Friday night
and there were two tables of NBA reps
there. No lie. I can provide picks for
verification. I don't want any pictures.
Don't send me any pictures.
I don't want to rat anybody out here.
I just think it's hilarious. Anyways,
anyway, I know that reps gets paid,
referees get paid 10 grand
per game for the NBA finals.
So if the series gets swept,
it's uh, it's 40 grand.
But if it goes to seven games,
that's a difference of 30 grant.
I work in finance and that's a lot of
coin for an extra three days of work,
plus the network gets more money from
advertisers, et Cetera. Although as sport,
uh, although a sport,
it's a major business.
I don't know what that sentence
means. A former ref Tim, Donna,
he got busted for gambling on games a
while back and wrote a book about it.
This is my favorite thing. They say that
that guy has no credibility. You know,
that's what they said
about Jose can Cinco,
when he first came out and you know what
was ratting everybody out, like, oh,
he's all these better. He's turned his
back on baseball. Uh, wait a minute.
He's right. Nope, sorry
about that. You know,
plus if you say he has no credibility,
then you have to like let 80% of people
out of prison because that's how they
ended up in prison. The person they did
the crime with was negotiating their,
their fucking sentence down
and they ratted him out.
Right. I don't know. I think
the NBA is filthy. You know,
Pete Rose Bets on baseball.
He's banned from baseball for life.
Jordan bets on it and he
gets to go play baseball,
allegedly, allegedly, uh,
former ref Tim, Donna,
he got busted for gambling on games
a while back, wrote a book about
it. The guy is from the same neighborhood
as I am and we know some of the same
people.
The guy that does my homeowner's insurance
was named as a gambling pat and I in
the first chapter.
It's eye opening of how shady the business
is and how reps can cheat so easily
to fix the outcome of a game.
According to Tim [inaudible], Dani,
this is all alleged people, all it
Philadelphia is a hotbed for NBA Reps.
And I actually went to high school with
an active Nba Ref who was also at the
above mentioned wedding.
Uh, I love the podcast,
but just started listening a few months
ago. How can I download the camp?
The dude,
you didn't really say anything.
He just said you went to a
wedding with some NBA Reps.
You know how much they make a game,
but you didn't really provide any.
That's all circumstantial.
I Dunno.
It just seems so filthy.
Like they call like the,
when they call those ticky tack files,
I'm telling you,
they're thinking ahead in the
game as, as how I look at it.
Like I get Paul Pierce files out.
But like those bullshit ticky tack files
that you call on him in the beginning
of the game is how we ended
up falling out when the end,
when he actually follows somebody. So
I don't, I don't know. I don't get it.
I'm sitting there watching us.
We got a 15 point lead and then
all of a sudden within a minute,
Paul Pierce in Rondo,
both pickup there.
Fourth files have to sit down and next
thing you know, it's a game again.
Okay.
You know, so I don't know
that they necessarily, I,
this is the feeling that I
have when I watched the NBA,
I feel like somewhere around 14,
15 point lead in the playoffs,
the playoffs,
um, that's when all of a sudden, you know,
calls started going the other way because
they don't want people to turn the
channels at the end of the fucking day.
It's a business.
Okay.
They keep it close. Just keep a close.
That's what they're doing. I don't know.
I'm an asshole now listen to me,
but I I 100%
okay.
It, it just wouldn't surprise
me if somebody came out
and they actually found out
that like 18% that's a little high.
I'd say 11% of NBA Games
are strongly manipulated.
I would be surprised that a PR that it
wasn't more like 18% cause when I just
watch him, it's just like how
many times can they just be like,
there's like no foul in that did shit.
I know we talked about it last week,
but Coby hacks,
a guy across both fucking arms,
they call him for his third
foul in the second quarter,
you know he's going to sit down. That's
going to affect the casual fan watching.
They have a 92nd meeting and then they
give the file to somebody else and that's
a business move right fucking there.
And then the announcer says,
I don't have a lot.
They'll look good at their raw right.
Kobi bringing it up the court
fucking nuts. She was in the front.
There's a file away from the ball
cheese. What was he looking at? I don't,
it must've been something
before the video. There was act.
They act like perplexed. All
right, here's his sexuality
situation. Everybody, um, hey bill,
I need your advice on something.
Uh, this is, uh, not, this is not about
a breakup dating are gold diggers,
but I think your advice could help me,
could help me out on an
extremely awkward position.
I'm 19 and I'm home from
college for this Ama.
I've been home for about a month
and I live in North Carolina,
but go to college in Arizona.
Dude,
good move Arizona with all those fucking
whores out there coming to class and
like bikini tops and you're out there
with your Q to than cute southern draw.
How much Asah you get? Well,
let's find out. Shall We? Okay.
While I was away at college, I have
opened up to new ideas such as politics,
politics,
religion,
and about my sexuality and
my bike and I am bisexual.
At the beginning of summer I started
hanging out with my old friends from high
school. One of which was gay. We
had messed around in high school,
but nothing serious. What does that
mean? You flicked his balls a little bit.
Sorry. The fucking joke is there. I'm
going to do it. All right. Come on.
Take it like a man like everybody else.
Okay. Everybody gets trashed on this.
Here we go.
So this summer he and I were hanging
out at my house and nobody was home.
We started and we started to drinking.
Oh Gee, she's playing some music.
Why am ca and he started
to smoke some weed, man.
Then after about two hours,
we decided to do the dirty Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Okay. Here we go. Slugging away through
here. Halfway through US getting it on.
My mom walks into the room
and catches us in the act.
Wow. Now talk about the needle
going off the fucking record.
She started yelling at me, swatting
me with the mail she had just gotten,
I'm surprised you didn't turn the hose on.
You kicked my friend out of the house.
Then banned him from ever coming over
again and started screaming about the
Bible and a bunch of religious shit.
By the way,
this all happened when I was in a,
in a panic trying to get some
clothes. Oh my God, Dude.
What a way to come out.
Oh,
I think it was Mitch was a giant neon.
I'm gay sign hanging over you.
Wow. That's a fucking
situation there, Huh.
Ever since then,
my mom and dad had been forcing me to
go to a few religious nut jobs that are
supposed to convert me from
bisexual to heterosexual.
That's hilarious.
You know,
like you're going to convert a truck from
two wheel drive, the four wheel drive,
like it's that fucking easy. This is
a huge pain in the ass because one,
there are churches on every
corner and North Carolina and two,
I don't want to change, so you
shouldn't do it. You can't.
You are who you fucking are and they're
going to have to accept it. Also,
my parents had
been treating me differently now and it's
really weird and awkward every time we
talk. So I guess my question is
how do I deal with this dude?
This is might be outside the realm
of my lack of extra expertise here.
Do I tell them that I don't want to go
to some religious fat fuck who was a
Jesus Freak and whose stomach
is as long as his vowels.
I always,
you've got that southern draw.
You can't bleed suck in day yet.
Um,
or should I just pretend to be straight
until the end of the summer then go back
to living the life I wanna
live at college also.
How do I keep saying with people telling
me that I am living my life wrong and
that God is judging me. Hope that wasn't
too sad dude. It's a fucking epic story.
Thank you for Shea. Sharon it here. Um,
all right. This is the deal dude. You,
you need new friends.
You need to keep the friends that accept
you for who you are and the ones who
aren't, you just got to phase
them out. Your parents were,
your parents will come around,
you know,
they got to come around cause
you're, you're their son.
Alright. Stereotypically,
probably your mom before
your dad or whatever, but I
don't know, maybe they will,
maybe they won't.
But what the fuck are you going to do?
Okay.
You know, you are who you are. You've got
to go be who you're going to be. And uh,
as far as do you tough it out for the
summer, that, that's up. That's up to you.
That's up to you. If you're
going to keep going back. I mean,
if I was going to keep going
back to some shit that I wanted,
I didn't want to go to,
I would just,
I,
I would have fun with it.
I would just act like a fucking moron
and I would keep acting like I was almost
cured.
And then at the last second be like,
but don't you think John Travolta's
cute? Oh, no, no. Sorry. Sorry.
I'm just fuck with the guy who just have
a good time. If he can't get out of it.
If you don't want to, you
know, fight, you know,
if you don't want to be like Hitler and
try and fight on three fronts and ended
up in a fucking bunker, uh,
maybe just start with the,
get some new fucking friends. Uh,
that's it, dude. That's brutal,
man. That's brutal. But,
uh, you'll get through it.
You'll get through it and you'll find some
fucking people, you know? I don't know.
It's weird. In a weird way. Everybody
does that beyond that shit. You know,
as a comedian, I never fit in
anywhere. Everywhere I went,
like when I fucking had jobs and they,
we'd be sitting there and I had my little
Michael J. Fox fucking suit and tie on,
like thinking that,
that this is what I was going to do.
And everybody was going in for some
fucking meeting. I'd never gave a fuck.
And I never,
I just felt,
always felt like an outsider until
the day I walked into a comedy club.
And I basically found people who were
the same kind of weird that I was.
So they didn't seem weird to me.
Committedly comedians were
all out of our fucking mind.
So that's what you have
to do in a gay way.
You just got to go find some heterosexuals
who are accepting of you and go get
some gay friends and you know you're going
to have a great life and you're going
to have abs until you're 60 evidently.
Cause that's how it works with gay people.
Fuck them. B, O, u, R and a. That's
it. All right. There you go. All right.
Dealing with girlfriend's mom,
girlfriend's mother.
Dear Bill. Yum. I'm 24 years
old. You know it's funny,
I always do this as this Boston accent.
I think that it fucks with my language
for the rest of the week. My language. No,
my accent for the rest of the week. I'm
24 years old and recently started. Let's,
let's see if I can pronounce
my rs through all of this.
I'm 24 years old and recently started,
started dating a new Gal.
She's a complete sweetheart.
Sorry. Also 24 years old,
but her mom already hates me.
What do you got? A mullet.
You got an earring, you got a
loud car. Do you got that? Look,
I'm going to fuck your daughter.
What's going on with you? Uh, he says,
I'm a pretty successful guy for my
age, college graduate. I have a house,
legit office job, et Cetera. How
the fuck you got a house at 24.
Okay.
Do you come from money or are you dealing,
okay,
dude,
if you're a college graduate and you
legitimately found a job and were able to
buy a house, like at a, I don't know,
like you've probably like one of five
people from your generation that's able to
do that with his fucking economy.
So I'll give you the benefit of the doubt.
Congratulations.
I'll give you the benefit of the doubt
that you don't have a meth lab in Europe
bathroom. Um, anyways, the
girl that girl's lives at home,
and before she was, uh, before me, she
was dating a guy in medical school.
Her mom crept through my Facebook profile
and decided based on the suburb I'm
from, the school I went to,
when the fact I'm not a doctor,
I'm not good enough for a daughter.
Uh,
which means she probably pressured her
daughter to go data fucking doctor or you
know, she dated a doctor trying to make
her mom happy. That's what I'm guessing.
[inaudible] was my lack of a
psychology degree. Um, but my,
my cynical way of looking at stuff,
uh,
well after three months of dating and
accepting, I might be around for a while.
They finally agreed to meet me. Her Dad
seems like a nice guy. It's just the mom.
I have two air quote in press.
So here's the issue.
I can't play the Red Knights redneck
stereotype too hard by wearing acid wash
jeans and a def Leppard tee shirt
because my girl will get pissed off.
But to my, my advantage, I own two cars,
both of which will annoy her
and deem me a fucking Hick. Uh,
which option in your
opinion would be funnier?
Parked in the wraparound driveway
of their million dollar house.
And now he sent me pictures of
his two fucking sweet rides.
He's got a 2006 Ford Mustang Gt.
This is my daily drivers blue with silver
racing stripes and lower two inches.
I have the cats removed and full exhaust.
I don't know what that means.
What catalytic converters?
I have no idea what that even means.
I just love that you
assume that. I know. Um,
so it's loud as shit and it's a five
speed so I can play like I sucked at
driving a stick and do the rev and release
clutch move that all 16 year olds do.
That should rattle their stainless steel
appliances and granite countertops.
Number two.
I've got a 1991 Ford f one 54 by four.
My bad weather slash housework.
Uh,
I think you beat her real better.
Three 51 Windsor motherfucker,
two tone red and white
single cab red bench seat.
It has plenty of NRA stickers on the
back from the previous owner and my
favorite being fight crime. Shoot
back a dude. That's it. That's a wrap.
Okay.
That's a wrap you got, I think you've
got to go with the truck. Fender wells,
a rusty a rusting out and there's
several rustles in the bed.
It also leaks cooling and oil and it
would leave a nice stain in the driveway.
I don't plan on being a dick
or anything when I meet them,
but she's going to judge
me without even knowing me.
I'd hate to let her down and close to
pictures of both cars and the bumper
sticker on the truck. Please advise. Uh,
that's what we say at the end of emails
and bullshit. Corporate America. Oh,
please, please advise. Um,
well those are beautiful cars,
man.
Yeah,
I love to Tom Pickup trucks too, by the
way. Uh, this is what I, yeah, pull up,
pull up in your pickup and then
the next time you come over,
you come over in the car and that'll do
the other stereotype that people, uh,
who don't come from money always,
you know, by depreciating assets.
Um,
I don't know.
Did it all depends on how much you
care about this girl because I,
your whole attitude is perfect. You
shouldn't give a fuck whether, uh,
she likes you or not. You
really shouldn't. There's
nothing you can do about it.
Just a, you know, romance or daughter if
you love her, if you don't get rid of her,
um, don't stick around
just out of spite. But, uh,
I would definitely go with
the pickup truck. The pickup
trucks. Fucking hilarious.
You know something. The mustangs cool too
though. That Mustang says, I, you know,
I'm going to bang your daughter
before we even get to the restaurant.
Okay.
It's loud.
Maybe the Mustang. Do you got a
mullet? How about a clip on earrings?
Um, I dunno. Anyways, anyways,
what the fuck else happened to me here?
I got to click back to my notes here.
It was a couple of stories I want to tell
you. I told the motorcycle one right?
Didn't I? Fucking nine hours. Oh Shit.
Where the fuck is it? There
we go. What the hell is it?
You know what? This fucking
computer man. Ah, yeah.
How sick you guys listen to
me bitch about my computer.
Let me just get rid of this. Oh
Shit. You know what I went to on? Um,
was it Wednesday of last week?
Thursday last week I went
down to the House of Blues.
They had the John Bonam a birthday bash.
It's become this,
this yearly thing with this cover band.
Basically not cover van.
It's like these insane fucking musician,
I guess they're all playing led Zeppelin.
They come out and then all
these drummers sit in and they,
and they play all these Zeplin tunes
and it's, it's the fucking shit man.
And there was some guys out
there who really, really
impressed me. Simon. It was,
it was crazy. Um, Freddy cupcake curry,
the nicest guy in rock and roll.
Now if you remember that from MTV
headbangers ball, you're showing your age.
He played a custard pie and Simon,
right?
The drummer for ACDC from 83 to 90,
he took over when Phil Rudd
got kicked out. And uh,
right before they did razor's edge,
1990,
he left to go play with dio and all.
I never really listened to deal
at least that part of his career.
And uh, all I heard was some just playing
the ACDC stuff, which was total two,
four, two, four stuff.
And he came out and play the
ocean and he fucking crushed it.
Phenomenal drummer.
But more importantly,
the last time I saw both those guys on
the same night I saw them play the old
Boston Garden. Cinderella was opening up
for eight ACDC on the heat secret tour.
Ah, you jealous? Is it a,
isn't it amazing that it took me 43 years
to find dirt bikes when you hear that
story?
But uh,
Freddie curry played custard pie and uh,
I felt there was two different,
they all the drummers there were great,
but I felt there was two
kinds of drummers that night.
There was the drama that was going up
there that loved John Bonham and was
paying tribute to him and,
and understood what it
was that John Bonham did.
And then there was the other guy,
what's,
this was a small portion went up there
and it was just a jerk off festival that
they were going to go up there and show
that they could play all the fucking
licks and they will play in all over the
kid throughout the song. And it just, uh,
I dunno,
one guy saw put the drum stick in his,
between his teeth as he was just
playing with his right hand.
And I was just thinking,
you know,
Bonham would have smashed a snare
drum over your fucking head.
What are you doing? What
are you doing? I mean,
was he biting on it because he felt he
geeked fucked up a lick? I have no idea,
but it was annoying.
Fucking annoyed me. Um, oh,
it started off great. The guy
who organizes it, Brian Tissue,
I think he organized it.
He played in the evening and man,
he just fucking crushed it.
And uh,
I was in my John Bonam glory and um,
and then Sebastian Bach came out and
sang whole lot of love. It was just,
it was just the shit.
And the last time I saw Sebastian
Bach live was December 31st,
1989. I had just lost my light
license for drinking and driving
and I saw Aerosmith at the Boston Garden
to bring in the decade of the 1990
[inaudible]. That's how I went out
of the 80s. It was on the done,
not, don't always say done with
mirrors. It was the pump tour. And, uh,
Aerosmith was silver by then,
so they started fucking incredible.
And that was that classic story I told
you where when that concert was going on
was right around the time when,
uh,
another bad egg that
the United States said,
invested in Manuel Noriega down in Panama,
all of a sudden wasn't doing what the
fuck we wanted to do. One of them to do,
you know the deal,
all these dark bags,
they're all doing shit that
we don't want it to do,
but they're doing what we need them to do.
So it's okay.
And then the second they stopped
doing what we needed to do,
all of a sudden were outraged that they
gassed their own people fucking 12 years
earlier.
How could he have done that at 1973?
We got to go on and get this right?
Uh,
there's like the fucking Coby Brian Foul.
90 seconds later they give it
to somebody else. It's like,
what the fuck have you been talking about?
So anyways,
so you know,
they're pumping us with
all the information about
Manuel Noriega and none of it
is good.
So you know, so he goes up there in
the middle of this fucking metal show.
He decides, I know I told this
story before, but I love this story.
He decided out of the
fucking blue to go political.
I remember he was standing on stage
and he might've been drunk, just, just,
you know,
for him to save face,
but he was wearing these leather pants
and I just, him standing there, he goes,
what's up with this man? Well, and
he grabbed his dick and he goes,
suck my fucking Burrito,
man.
Yep.
Fucking a rhythmic.
And it was this awkward pause and
everything just went very starched chair.
And he goes,
I'd seen,
he said something about going
down there and fucking Newcomb.
It was the classic and for all you conn
silver in England, the guys from Canada.
So go fuck yourself.
All right.
You think now the typical stupid
guy from the states, all right,
might've been pandering, but I got to
tell you, we all cheered. That's right.
Sebastian,
you figure out Central America
and then play slave to the grind.
Oh No, no. That was their
first tour. That's a new thing
in 18 in life. You got it
right. And all the chicks are like, oh my
God, look at me when I take my tits out.
Oh,
those were the days.
All those fucking fish netted horse whose
flows the greatest fucking thing ever.
I'm really so happy that I grew up
during that time rather than the grunge
period when all those hairy checks would
just fucking walking around with this
Sasquatch muffs, you know,
high and tight eighties baby.
It was right before the really bad news.
Two things that were really
bad and the nineties like,
you know that grunge music, you
know, the top tier I like all right.
But there was a lot of moping around
just because moping around was selling
albums the same way with hair metal.
There was a lot of shit
about the devil and you know,
they weren't really
sacrificing anybody. Right. Um,
it was only the top shelf that
were, but anyways, the, the,
the mopey music of the
90s and then the fucking,
the just absolutely perfect circle,
horrific grapefruit fake tits where you
had like a varicose vein on the side of
your titty. Like those two
of the worst things from the
90s, I would say, you know,
one of the best things for the 90s
I would say would be sound garden.
I go with them.
Um,
I'm sure I could play a fucking email,
Dave,
fuck these jug gang actually ripped up.
I don't give a shit. You guys like me.
Anytime you computer comes up and says,
hey, there's new software available. Yeah.
Would you like to download it? And you've
got that option. Not now. You know,
like hitting the snooze alarm on your
fucking computer and then one day you go
to your,
iTunes doesn't work.
Now the video works and then you
yell at your computer. Like it's the,
it's the problem. That's what
I like to do. Hey everybody,
if you've been to the post office
lately, yeah. How did that work out?
Wouldn't it be wonderful if somehow you
could take the enormity of the stove,
the postal industry, and just stick it
inside your, of your, of your apartment,
put her right in your little sleeping
bag. Wouldn't that be great? Well,
I'm here to tell you that
that's a possibility.
If you go to stamps.com everybody,
um,
you can stop one of the biggest
wastes of time in your life right now,
which is going to the post
office, especially when
you've got a business to run.
Or maybe you just want to sit
down and eat a sandwich, right?
That's why you need stamps.com.
It's not only going to save you time,
you can buy and print official us postage
using your own computer or a friends
and a printer.
Print exact postage for any letter,
right from your desk using
the free digital scale. Um,
the exact posters for a letter or
package. Sorry, I read that wrong.
Basically anything you want to ship,
you can stick that baby in a box
and put it on a scale. You know,
maybe you need some help. Now you've got
a friend, right? You have him pick it up,
you put it on the damn scale,
you weigh it,
you put the postage right on the park out,
you're putting your post office box,
whatever, your mailbox, and then you go
right back to watching t bill. We know,
we know what we would do if we had the
post office in our own apartments or
houses or outhouses or tense.
Do you live in a tent city?
Do you have an outlet?
Uh, by stamps.com uh,
but stamps.com we'll also give you money.
It's a fraction of the cost of a
postage meter. Plus you get discounts.
She can't even get at the post office.
That's a great thing if you get an early
with stamps.com because once it blows
up, you know that they're not
gonna have any of these discounts.
So you get an early, all right, I'm
sure. I'm going to get a note on that.
Actually plan on having
death counts forever. Uh,
right now if you use my last name Berbee
you are are for this special offer,
you get a no risk trial plus $110 bonus
offer that includes a digital scale and
up to $55 in free postage.
Don't wait.
This is the call to action. Everybody
go to stamps, duck stamps.com right now.
Before you do anything else,
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burpee you
are,
are that stamps.com enter bur and you
will be in the wonderful world of not
having to go to the post office anymore.
You know,
that'd be great.
What if he had the grocery store in your
own apartment? That's probably be next.
Go to grocery store jet Com.
Wouldn't it be great if Lehmans fell
out of your ceiling? Do you know? Uh,
the wonderful, the beautiful,
the lovely Nia has been, uh,
she's been on a tear lately,
you know,
planting all his shit out in the
Yad and uh, none of it's edible.
So we're having this big fight. Like
she likes pretty smell. It smells good.
I like it. It's Lilac. It's like
you can't fucking eat that shit.
You know? Why don't we get a a, you know,
like a watermelon tree is something,
right? Why email is don't go fuck
yourself. I know they don't grow on trees.
You know what I mean?
Let's get something edible out here.
Let's grow some goddamn
potatoes. You know, scope,
grow some fucking food
is what I want to do.
They got those little dwarf trees
like a midget, a grapefruit tree.
They got a midget avocado
tree and they just,
you just stick them in a barrel and
then you go park. Alex comes, it comes.
Jesus thrown all the sinners down into
hell and you just sitting there eating
Avocados. Like, go fuck
yourself. You hippie.
I got a food supply when he got
to do to make the end of the day.
I know you're a pacifist.
I know you don't got it in you.
You don't have that rage like your
dad does. Talent skips a generation.
All right, why don't you go play the
fucking Maracas and get out of my face?
I know that's not your three headed
dog. That's your dad's. Yeah, go for,
look, I respect your dad.
I'm not disrespecting now
and disrespect and you, yeah,
I'm sure that's how you're going to
tell the story of fucking pussy. Right?
All while you're eating an avocado
or grapefruit or some shit like that.
You know, recently I worked with
somebody and they said something about a
um,
they said something about the a microwave.
I don't think I can ever use one again.
He said they microwave water to
boiling point and let it cool down.
And then they boil some water on the
stove and they water two rows of flowers
and the water with the microwave water,
they all died.
So I'm all set on the microwave. That's
all it takes. That kills a plant.
What's it doing to me?
I don't know.
I'm easily scared everybody and I'm
very, I'm not, I'm not trusting.
So if you have any remote like
theory on anything, like, you know,
I would literally phase out,
uh, living in a house if,
if you a good enough lie as to
why it was slowly killing me.
Um, anyways, what else do we got here?
What are they have I promised
I would resend this to you.
Run this whenever you would like.
All right, this is spotify.com.
All right. This is one of these places
that you, you, uh, Oh for Christ sake.
What is this? This is the graphic image.
Why don't I have this stuff ready?
The worst, you know, this is why I'm
a comedian because I swear to God,
if I was in the real world and
I had some sort of presentation,
I would be the guy showing up with like
the papers falling out of my briefcase
at what? Atlanta. I meant to say it
would be like the nutty professor,
but I would never turn into the cool
guy. Jerry Lewis is by the way. Um,
what is Spotify? Uh,
it's a new way to listen.
Listen to free to listen to music
for free. Millions of tracks,
artists and even co comedic content is
on there for you to access whenever you
want. I know what a lot
of you guys think at bill,
why you're hyping this stuff when you
had a problem with that other site.
Because this site actually is going to
pay me for my material so I don't have a
problem with them. So go down
to Spotify, everybody. Um,
this is why the way I,
I think about Spotify is iTunes,
but with the entire world's live,
oh is this one I'm supposed to say?
This is what I think you
guys are speaking for me.
Evidently Spotify is like iTunes,
but with the entire world's library
at your fingertips will right there.
That's better than iTunes.
How many times you go on Itunes,
you go to look up a band and they don't
have it unless it's like the biggest
thing ever.
You know like your guilty
pleasures at that kid.
They'll actually have the be tracks
of Brittany Spears on Spotify.
It works on a PC.
It works on a Mac home audio system
and mobile phones tracks play live.
There's no need to wait for downloads
and no big dense in your hard drive.
Spotify connects seamlessly with your
Facebook account and allows to easily
discover new music and
share them with friends.
Super easy to use and is what you do.
You go to the Spotify link on the website,
Click register from your Facebook account,
download Spotify to your windows or Mac
computer search and play the millions of
songs that are now yours.
During it, they say,
we'll give you free access access to
Spotify, and it's really just that simple.
Um, Bill, do you have a
deal for us? Yes, I do.
For every one of my
listeners that I drive to a,
those is the actual deal that I get.
Every one I drive there,
I get a free quarter of a grilled cheese
sandwich for listen to. So it's a,
it's a whole sandwich. Um, banner
ad is attached to the email.
We don't even have this up yet. I'm
going to have to hit, AH, Jesus Christ.
Why did I do that? You know
what you did? That's like,
you just got somebody leaked.
Copy the tracks of their new album.
We're going to have that up for next
week. Everybody, all spotify.com
boy. Oh boy, this is the
greatest thing ever says bill.
I like when this copy like that. I
don't even have to think. Um, anyways,
so let's get back to the podcast here.
What do we got here?
We got some overrated underwriters.
We've got to wind this down here, right?
What are we up to? An hour
and two minutes, Bill. Yeah,
but here or leaving them wanting more.
All right.
We've gone through the advice dealing
with girlfriend's mom or his last one.
It's entitled Virgin lack of the Jade.
Hey,
who here wouldn't still Bang Madonna?
Huh?
I just thought she'd be so fucking
annoying though. Just shut up.
You're from Detroit. You not have me with
your dumb accent. Uh, I'm 21 years old,
dude. Just graduate to Bobby Kelly,
right? This, I'm 21 years old gig.
Do you guys listen to the,
what the fuck podcast or Christopher
Titus is podcasts and I'm going to be on
that.
I don't even know the name of,
I actually just went and did his podcast
and I didn't even learn the God damn
name of it because I'm so wrapped up
in my own thing. You know, it's funny,
as I went to the search thing and I
actually searched cricket is gay because I
wanted to see what Jason Alexander said.
Uh,
all right, Chris Titus podcast.
You know what's great about us doing
the podcast? If there's any video of it,
you guys can actually see that we are two
different people tied his podcast.com.
There we go.
This is what you do.
You go to Titus podcast.com
and there's all kinds of music.
Uh, all right. It's just
called the tightest podcast.
He's got a cool logo. The son of a
bitch. Anyways, I did one of his,
and I actually just tweeted at
this this week, so there you go.
There's your homework this week.
Listen to the, what the fuck did? No,
not what the fuck. Oh, you know what dude?
What the fuck is Marin's?
You know what dude is Bobby Kellys
and the Christopher Titus podcasts.
Go to Titus podcast.com. All
right. If you like this podcast,
hell, you might even like
those. All right, virgin.
I'm a 21 year old virgin.
Do just graduated from college in La.
Is that Louisiana to Los Angeles
and one of my bigger issues,
that was a great Dennis Miller joke a
long time ago. Just got back from La.
I love Louisiana. Uh, yeah. Any,
one of my bigger issues in my life
right now is that I'm still a virgin.
The 21 that's not bad. Uh,
I'm not attractive. I'm not
unattractive or anything.
I work out,
have a bit of an issue with acne,
but it's nothing like having a
gigantic puss ball on my face.
I was in a relationship with a girl since
I was 14 and we ended it when I was 20
because we just couldn't deal
with the long distance anymore.
And she was really conservative Christian
and I guess I was naive and stupid
enough to tell her that I would wait.
That's not right. The, you're a good guy.
Therefore, the more we
went, the most we went,
all the most we went to was just oral sex.
All right.
Do we not like a terminal virgin?
You're actually doing,
you're living the life
you get your having sex,
like you have it like a one
of those massage parlors. Uh,
uh, we came close a couple
of times, but I don't,
I would always back out because I'd feel
bad that I would be running off with
the virginity because at the back of my
mind I kind of knew this relationship
was never going to work out. Jesus
Christ, dude, you're a saint.
It doesn't help that she and I
have had the same group of friends.
So if word got out, what I did, uh,
that would have been seen as a dick move.
Now that I'm actually single
and looking for chicks,
and on occasion I've actually managed
to convince a few to come home with me.
All right,
you're in the game.
I feel this innate sense of pressure that
I wouldn't be able to perform well and
would end up embarrassing myself due
to lack of experience doing unit.
You're going to be fine.
These nightly escapades would therefore
only tend to end up with out sessions or
the occasional finger bang
blow job before a pussy out.
Where do you think I should do,
should actually do in a situation like
these when I'm taking a check home who
probably has way more experienced
than I do and I should just,
should I just take a heavy dose of man
the fuck up and wing it in the future?
Uh, I wouldn't think of telling a girl
that I'm a virgin before fucking her.
Which sound remotely attractive
to her in any circumstance.
What are your thoughts on
this? Yeah, Dude. You know
what you gotta do? Just like,
look,
you know,
I got good at playing hockey or halfway
decent upper level of sucking your like
I gradually got to the truth on that.
I ain't met the upper, upper sucking,
not quite lower mediocre.
How I got there was I played with
people who had more experience than me.
All right, so just slide that over
to bang in these girls. All right.
And I don't think that they, the girls
aren't like that. Then I can, uh,
what is she going to do? All My god,
you never fucked anyone before Jesus.
I fucked like 900 guys. They're not going
to say that. I think he'd be like, Oh,
and next thing you know, you can be
banging on the fucking doggy style.
That'll be a thrill for him.
You know, you put on the,
the the fucking soundtrack
to the graduate, you know,
you have a good time. Yeah.
Just, just look, you know what the thing
about this is, is the more you wait,
the bigger of a fucking deal it's
going to be. You know what I mean?
It's like icing the kicker
and the kicker is your Dick.
All right for God, say, get out there
and fucking blasted through the uprights.
That's what you needed
to do. All right. And uh,
you sound like you're doing great
man. You're a good guy too. Junior.
You realize the fucking, the,
the, the, I don't know what it is.
I don't even know what the word is
cause none of my friends have this,
this character trait.
I'm sure women know what it is and
they probably look forward in a guy.
Okay,
a gentleman, Jesus. I had to
search for it. What a what a just,
you're a human being, dude.
You were an honest guy.
You could have banged
this girl and you're like,
I can't do it because I in the back of my
head, you actually, you know, you know,
it's funny.
You're probably bang a couple of girls.
You become a piece of shit like me, but
right now, dude, you're in the zone.
Mother Teresa couldn't fuck with you. You
know, Jesus comes back tomorrow, Dude.
He's fucking your write up on that horse
smelling of puts.
Surely when you fucking grab around his
waist and right into having to look at
what a disgusting image anyways. Yeah
Dude, just, just man the fuck up.
We get the future and uh,
you know what?
You know what I think would get
rid of a lot of the pressure.
Why don't you just tell them,
you know,
I dunno if you feel like the
moments there, just tell them.
If you just feel like the moments there,
you don't have to come the whole
fucking story just in the middle of it.
Just telling me I never,
never did this before.
That's okay.
You know, next thing you got their
feet in the air. I'm telling you,
you're going to be fine. All right?
And you're a good person and a,
there's the deal, dude. You're a fucking
virgin. All right? So you're like a,
you still got that new car smell.
All right? So whatever you do,
alright, condoms from here on out.
Condoms, mirror on out. No fucking skanks.
All right? Cause they have a
dental. Even if you wear a condom,
you can still get fucked. You know
things. I'm not going to do this.
And now you get even more
in your head right now.
What I just did is now you finally lined
up to ticket to kick the field goal.
And I'm sitting there waving my arms with
the fucking Air Horn in the background.
Just,
you know,
okay.
Fucking around. And it's like boxing.
Protect yourself at all times. All right?
That's all I'm going to say.
Okay. All right, good luck to you.
That's the podcast for this week.
Apologize for being late.
I hope my story about riding a motorcycle.
What the fuck happened to my taint?
Jesus Christ. It just sat in this
chair the wrong way. My fucking,
my fucking Tate hurts. Ah, fuck.
You know what it was was I went over
a couple of fucking jumps and I got a
little bit of air and I
didn't own enough to stand up.
So I kind of came off the seat and
then landed and fucking slam my taint.
He liked that people.
I jacked my thumb up,
my shoulders talking to me and uh,
I took a nice fucking slam,
a couple of slams to the Tate.
I'm going to call the comedy store.
Tell him I can't perform this week
because of a bruise taint. Um,
are you fucking with us? I'm dead serious.
Hang on a second. You've got the iPhone.
I'll take a video.
That's disgusting. Well,
it's your fault for hanging out
for the whole podcast. All right,
go fuck yourself. That's the podcast for
this week. I'll talk to you next week.
Don't take any shit,
and uh,
God bless everyone today,
okay. All right. Bye.